mesdames messieurs bonjour La la séance
est ouverte mes chers collègues nous
reprenons donc les auditions de notre
commission d'enquête sur la TNT nous
recevons donc les dirigeants des groupes
audiovisuels actifs sur la la TNT et
donc ce matin des dirigeants de Energie
group donc monsieur beaucrou PDG madame
sali Directrice Déléguée la direction
générale du groupe madame Chana ici
présente direct général adjointe et
Monsieur Pavard gérant de énergie
12 je vous remercie de prendre le temps
de de de répondre à notre invitation
donc le groupe dispose de deux
autorisations d'mettre sur la
TNT Energie 12 qui fait partie des
toutes premières chaînes autorisées à
émettre sur la TNT à partir de de 2005
qui a été renouvelé en 2019 avec une
échéance donc en 2025 et puis Chéry 25
qui a été retenue en 2012 reconduite en
2022 pour une durée qui nous amène
jusqu'à
2027 je vais vous passer la parole pour
une intervention liminaire de 10 minutes
pour l'ensemble l'ensemble du groupe je
vous remercie également de nous déclarer
tout intérêt public ou privé qui serait
de nature à influencer vos déclaration
et je vous rappelle évidemment comme on
le fait à à chaque fois que l'article 6
de l'ORD ance du 17 novembre
1958 relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité je vous invite donc
Mesdames Messieurs à lever la main
droite et à dire je le
jure je vous remercie vous avez donc la
parole pour ce propos liminire d'une
dizaine de minutes pour nous expliquer
la la situation les perspectives du
groupe et puis nous en viendrons par la
suite aux questions de de programmation
et de renouvellement de l'autorisation
des maîtres je vous laisse la
parole du du groupe nous nous accompagne
est ici très bien ben monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les membres de la
commission et députés votre commission a
souhaité nous entendre dans le cadre de
son enquête et c'est bien volontiers que
nous répondons à cette demande donc je
suis présent aujourd'hui au côté de
Monsieur Hervé Pavard qui est le
représentant légal de nos chaînes de
télévision et gérant de la chaîne
Energie 12 ainsi que président de ché HD
de Madame Céline Chana qui est
directrice générale adjointe du pôle
télévision de Mariam madame Mariam sali
directrice déléguée à la direction
générale du groupe et de Monsieur
Philippe boindriilleux comme je vous le
disais qui est directeur délégué
finances du groupe énergie je
souhaiterais brièvement vous présenter
notre groupe Energy Group qui est côté
sur le marché Euron nextte à Paris
Energy Group est présent dans le paysage
audiovisuel depuis plus de 40 ans en
radio et en télévision depuis l'origine
de la TNT dès 2003 et pour mémoire même
en
1986 avec la chaîne nationale et
gratuite TV6 que nous avons exploité au
côté de gaumon et de Publicis pendant
une année je passerai ensuite la parole
à à RV Pavard pour vous présenter nos
chaînes et plus particulièrement la
chaîne Energie 12 sa genèse et son
positionitionnement dans la TNT gratuite
nous serons enfin naturellement à votre
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
éventuelles alors voilà voici plus de 40
ans que le groupe Energie que j'ai eu
l'honneur de créer à partir d'un petit
studio d'habitation de 25 m² début de
chaumon et c'était l'époque des radios
libres effervescente et donc le groupe
que je préside aujourd'hui trace son
sillon dans le secteur de l'audiovisuel
en s'inscrivant dans une stratégie de
dével développement à la fois audacieuse
et pérenne ces atouts nous ont permis de
développer un groupe multimédia
indépendant l'histoire du groupe
ennergie c'est celle d'un groupe de
médias qui est né avec les radios libres
comme je vous le disais et qui a
développé quatre réseaux radiophonique
ennergie chéri FM nostalgie et rire et
chanson j'espère d'ailleurs que certains
d'entre vous sont auditeurs auditrices
et qui s'adresse à des publics très
divers et rassemblent chaque jour plus
de 10 millions d'auditeurs en
France Energie est la première marque
radio internationale présente dans 17
pays faisant ainsi rayonner nos marques
et le savoir-faire français à
l'international c'est l'un des pionniers
de la TNT avec Energie 12 lancé en 2005
puer 25 en 2012 qui réunissent ensemble
chaque jour 7300000 spectateurs sans
compter la chaîne 100 % musicale
énergite qui est présente sur l'univers
du
CAPSAT le groupe par ailleurs contribué
avec son opérateur de diffusion
towerCast qui est aujourd'hui la
principale alternative à l'opérateur
dominant TDF à construire le réseau de
la TNT et à diffuser les services de
télévision sur le territoire
national au-delà des enjeux particuliers
sectoriel la TNT est plus largement la
diffusion dite en broadcast représente
un enjeu de souveraineté nationale dans
un secteur bousculé par les plateformes
et géants du numérique qui ont pu
pénétrer le marché français sans au unee
barrière à l'entrée la TNT doit ainsi
être pérénisée dès lors qu'elle
constitue un rempart pour l'indépendance
le dianisme et la souveraineté du modèle
de l'exception culturelle française la
TNT mode de diffusion plus écologique
est également garante de gratuité et
d'anonymat proposant ainsi au français
une offre télévisuelle régulée gratuite
riche et
pluriel le groupe énergie dispose enfin
d'une situation financière solide sans
endettements fruit d'une gestion
prudente son chiffre d'affaires s'est
élevé en 2022 à
380400000 € et son résultat opérationnel
courant à
45800000 pour votre parfaite information
le chiffre d'affaires 2023 sera publié
ce soir après Bourse mais c'est surtout
une force vive de plus de 1500
collaborateurs don plus de 600
collaborateurs en région et plus de 200
l'innational et si vous me le permettez
je souhaiterais saluer leur engagement
et leur implication je suis très fier
d'eux vous le voyez Energy Group c'est
une histoire de réussite à la française
et nous en sommes très fiers je laisse
maintenant la parole à Hervé Pavard qui
va vous parler de notre pôle
télévision monsieur le Président
Monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
Messieurs les les membres de la
commission et députés Energie 12 a été
autorisé le 10 juin 2003 dans le cadre
de l'appel à candidature du 24 juillet
2001 la chaîne a débuté en TNT en 2005
et est passé en en Haute Définition en
2016 comme les autres chaînes autorisées
en 2005 l'autorisation de l'énergie 12 a
été prorogé en 2012 pour 5 ans en
contrepartie d'un engagement de
couverture supplémentaire du territoire
national énergie 12 a ensuite été
reconduit par le CSA hors appel à
candidature le 29 mai 2019 dans le cadre
de la procédure pré vu par l'article 281
2 de la loi du 30 septembre 1986 modifié
le CSA relevant expressément à cette
occasion qu'aucun manquement ne
s'opposait à une telle reconduction son
autorisation arrivera donc à échéance le
28 février 2025 chéri 25 elle a été
autorisée le 3 juillet 2012 dans le
cadre de l'appel à candidature d'octobre
2011 la chaîne a commencé sa diffusion
le 12 décembre 2012 sur la TNT chéri 25
a ensuite été reconduite par l'arcom
hors appel à candidature le 9 mars 2022
dans dans le cadre toujours de la
disposition de l'article 281-2 de la loi
de 86 modifiée l'arcom relevant aussi
expressément à cette occasion qu'aucun
manquement ne s'opposait à la
reconduction de l'autorisation de
chéif25 l'autorisation de chéif 25
arrivera donc elle à échéance le 11
décembre 2027 energy 12 est une chaîne
axée sur le divertissement chéry25
est-elle une chaîne dédiée aux femmes je
vais vous parler un petit peu plus
précisément d'énergie 12 au terme de sa
convention plus particulièrement de
l'article 311 energy 12 offre une large
variété de programmes dont une majorité
consacrée au divertissement cela fait
partie de l'ADN de la marque Energie et
la chaîne depuis son origine s'est
inscrite durablement dans cette ligne
éditoriale la chaîne propose ainsi une
offre de programme diversifié comprenant
principalement des divertissements des
uvres cinématographiques des fictions
télévisuelles mais aussi des magazines
et des documentaires suite au
renouvellement de son autorisation au
qui est applicable au 1er janvier
2020 la cette nouvelle convention marque
un renforcement des stipulations
relatives à la représentation de la
diversité de la société française à une
meilleure représentation des femmes à
l'antenne ainsi qu'une accessibilité
améliorer des programmes aux personnes
sourdes malentendantes aveugles
malvoyantes valeur auxquel le groupe
Energie a toujours attaché une la plus
grande importance dans le respect de sa
convention energy 12 a su s'imposer avec
une marque forte comme une chaîne
singulière avec un ton et une approche
qui se distingue des autres chaînes de
la TNT c'est la chaîne des rendez-vous
divertissants qui propose une
programmation avec pour maître mot
détente humour valeurs positiv et
rassembleuse à titre d'illustration
Energie 12 propose beaucoup de fictions
françaises
fédératrices comme Clem fais pas c fais
pas ça par en mode d'emploi mais aussi
une programmation cinématographique
variée pour tous les publics safari
jusqu'ici tout va bien premières vacan à
titre d'illustration des derniers film
qu'on a pu diffuser sur le thème de la
comédie sur des films d'action ou
policier je prendrai comme exemple le
gateur avec Daniel otol Matthieu
kassovic goofast avec avec rogisem ou le
protocole avec Clevis cornac on a aussi
des productions originales telles que
les Masters du rire qui donnent cartte
blanchees à des talent humoriste
naissant ou confirmé sur la scène de
l'Apollo théâtre et céine Chana vous en
parlera un tout petit peu plus
éventuellement après si vous avez des
questions sur ce sujet de l'humour avec
une offre généreuse de spectacles
vivants tel François Xavier de maison
les coquettes Arnaud de sa mère Baptiste
le capelin mais aussi des portraits
documentaires mettant à l'honneur des
artistes populaires notamment des
artistes
francophones des musiciens j mat pocora
soprano ou encore des acteurs français
tels que leilla Beti auars Florence
Foresti Jean du jardin c'est grâce à
cette programmation diversifiée que
nergie 12 se situe parmi les chaînes
dont le profil téléspectateur est l'un
des plus jeunes en fait le troème plus
jeune de l'ensemble de la TNT en France
et très très proche du second energy 12
rassemble chaque jour près de 5 millions
de téléspectateurs le pôle télé repose
sur ces deux chaînes qui sont nergie 12
et Chéry 25 complémentaire l'une de
l'autre et qui constitue un écosystème
vertueux pour notre groupe
on contribue aussi évidemment au titre
d'obligation mutualisé à la vitalité de
la production et de la création
française en 2022 le pôle télé a réalisé
un chiffre d'affaires de
79,9 million
d'euros je vous parlerai des obligations
on a deux grandes familles d'obligations
des obligations de diffusion qu'on
appelle couramment les quotas de
diffusion au terme de la réglementation
et Energie doit diffuser sur l'ensemble
de ces œuvres audiovisuelles diffusées
60 % d'œeuvres audio visuelle européenne
et 40 % d'œuvres audiovisuell
d'expression originale française ces
quotas sont appréciés annuellement par
le CS par l'arcom pardon aujourd'hui sur
l'année mais aussi sur les heures de
grande écoute pour vérifier que ces
quotas sont bien respectés sur les
heures de grande écoute qui sont 18h 23h
tous les jours et 14h 23h le mercredi
sur les œuvres cinématographiques
Energie 12 doit également diffusé sur
l'ensemble des œuvres cinématographiques
60 %
d'œuvres européennes et 40 % d'œuvres
cinématographiques d'expression
originale française là encore ces quotas
s'apprécient annuellement et aussi sur
la tranche de grande écoute qui est de
20h30 22h30 concernant les œuvres
cinématographiques au terme de la
convention Energie 12 doit consacrer au
moins la moitié de son temps total de
diffusion au divertissement au sens
large divertissement cinématographique
fiction audiovisuelle animation
spectacle concert tant le CSA que
l'arcom aujourd'hui ont expressément
constaté que energy 12 avait
parfaitement satisfait ensemble de ces
obligations de diffusion sur les 5
dernières années Energie 12 a aussi des
obligations là je vous ai parlé des
obligations de diffusion on a d'autres
obligations qui sont des obligation de
production au 1er janvier 2023 les
obligations de production de énergie 12
étaient mutualisé avec celle de Cherry
25 et constituai un investissement de 15
% de notre chiffre d'affaires net de
l'année précédente dans la production
audiovisuelle dont 8,5 % d'œuvres
patrimoniales notre obligation générale
donc qui est de 15 % de notre chiffre
d'affair net
doit aller à 70 % vers de la production
indépendante et notre
production notre obligation pardon
patrimoniale elle doit aller à 75 % vers
de la production indépendante production
indépendante c'est-à-dire un producteur
qui n'est ni détenu ni contrôlé
majoritairement par la chaîne et dont
les droits de diffusion qu'il nous cède
sont limités à 42 mois ennergie 12 doit
également consacrer 25 % de son
obligation à des programmes inédits tant
le CSA que l'arcom ont constaté que
Energie 12 avait parfaitement satisfait
ses obligations sur les 5 dernières
années récemment le 20 novembre 2023
nous avons signé un nouvel accord sur la
production avec les sociétés les
représentants de la filière production
ainsi que les auteurs euh nouvel accord
qui vise à renforcer nos engagements sur
quelques points par rapport à l'accord
précédent cet accord permettra notamment
aux chaîne du groupe d'acquérir des
droits linéaires et non linéaires plus
étendus pour l'ensemble des œuvres afin
de bien accompagner l'évolution des
usages dans le cadre de cet accord nous
sommes toujours à 15 % de chiffre
d'affaires net de l'année précédente
investi dans la production indivisuelle
mais désormais c'est 9% au lieu de 8,5
que nous investissons dans la production
d'œuvrees audiovisuell patrimonial et
72,5 % de notre obligation général
contre 70 auparavant qui sont consacrés
à de la production
indépendante cet accord renforce aussi
l'engagement du Groupe sur ces deux
chaînes énergie 12 et Chéry 25 au titre
de la production d'inédit l'arcom
vérifiera en 2024 la bonne exécution de
cet
accord puisqu'il est valable cet accord
sur 2023 donc c'est dans le bilan 2024
que l'arcom pourra vérifier qu'on a bien
tenu nos engagements Energie 12 doit
aussi consacrer 3,2 % de son chiffre
d'affaires annuel net à la production
d'œuvres cinématographique dont 2,5 %
d'œuvrees d'expression originale
française en conclusion j'aimerais vous
dire que le groupe Energie croit
pleinement au modèle de la TNT gratuite
qui est toujours largement plébiscité
par les Français et dans lequel nnerg1
on Chéry 25 ont toute leur place et
participent pleinement au pluralisme et
au financement de la création ainsi
depuis l'origine Energie 12 et Chéry 25
ont déclaré au titre de leurs
obligations de production 178 millions
d'euros d'investissement dans la
production et votre commission je crois
a auditionné euh des producteurs et vous
avez pu noter l'importance qu'ils
apportent qu'ils attachent à la
diversité des éditeurs euh dans dans ce
domaine dans un paysage marqué par le
développement ces dernières années des
plateformes la TNT conserve toute son
importance en
offrant une offre audiovisuel équilibré
tant en terme de diversité de thématique
et qui aussi est régulé la TNT conserve
son attractivité offrant une réception
gratuite
anonyme de nombreuses chaînes sur
l'ensemble du territoire nous nous
réjouissons de voir qu'un large
consensus existe aujourd'hui sur la
nécessité d'accompagner les éditeurs de
la TNT dans la modernisation de leurs
offres et et la capacité à répondre aux
défis pour continuer à faire de l'offre
de télévision gratuite qui est une offre
de référence dans un contexte
d'évolution et de digitalisation des
usages c'est à à cet égard d'ailleurs
que l'arcom a lancé une réflexion sur la
visibilité et la définition de ce qu'on
appelle les services d'intérêt général
pour la télévision pour nous c'est
quelque chose de fondamental et
d'extrêmement important puisqu'il
permettra de garantir la visibilité des
services de la TNT dans un environnement
numérique le groupe Energie considère
que doivent être déclaré servicees
d'intérêt général tous les services
autorisés en TNT nationale gratuite en
effet ces derniers ayant été
sélectionnés au termees d'appel à
candidatures qui ont permis d'établir de
manière objective et proportionnée leur
contribution au pluralisme et à la
diversité
culturelle je vous
remercie je je voudrais maintenant
aborder dans un premier temps la
l'aspect modèle économique de la TNT
notamment de de vos chaînes ensuite nous
aborderons la la question des des des
contenus euh monsieur becrou parlait du
chiffre d'affair et du résultat
opérationnel de du groupe je vrais
revenir sur les chiffres des deux
chaînes d'nergy 12 et Chéry 25
euh confirmez-vous qu'elle demeure
déficitaire à ce jour et comment vous
expliquez que vous n'ayez jamais pu
atteindre cet objectif de R abilité
nêtes pas les seuls évidemment modèle de
la TNT comme ça mais comment vous
expliquez selon vous que vous ayez du
mal à atteindre cet objectif de de
rentabilité est-ce que vous pouvez nous
détailler la structuration de vos coûts
notamment ce qui ce qui correspond au
coût de diffusion au coût des programmes
eux-mêmes bien évidemment à la masse
salariale et comment selon vous essayer
de concilier cet objectif de rentabilité
économique avec en même temps un
objectif de qualité des
programmes je vais je vais m'efforcer de
répondre le plus précisément possible à
à vos différentes questions bon
euh aujourd'hui comme le président becou
l'a dit on va publier le chiffre
d'affaires ce soir et le résultat
complet du groupe en 2023 23 sera publié
le 20 mars 2024 donc je je sais pas
commenter aujourd'hui quel sera le
résultat du pôle télé sur 2023 donc je
vais me référer à nos chiffres tels
qu'ils ont été publiés pour l'année
2022 donc oui en 2022 le groupe est en
enfin le pôle télé pardon est encore
légèrement déficitaire avec 4,5 million
d'euros de perte en 2022 sur un chiffre
d'affaires de
79,9 mais il faut surtout le mettre dans
une perspective et dans une dynamique en
l'espace de 6 ans nous sommes
passés d'un pôle télévision qui perdait
en moyenne 28,5 millions d'euros à 4,5
on verra le 20 mars ce que nous réserve
l'année 2023 donc on pense aujourd'hui
que en effet après des années de perte
on a
trouvé des moyens qui nous
permettent d'avoir une structure
économique qui se viabilise en
trouvant des fondamentaux entre le type
de
programme un une audience particulière
ciblée et du coup une monétisation de
cette audience qui va nous amener dans
une zone qui n'est plus du tout les
pertes qui a pu connaître auparavant le
le pôle
télé voilà après vous me parliez de la
répartition des coûts donc là aussi sur
l'année
2022 le coût des programmes représentait
47 % des charges du pôle télévision les
coûts de diffusion 16 % encore encore
une fois on est favorable à la
couverture quasi universelle du
territoire métropolitain en TNT c'est un
coup donc pour nous c'était 16 % de nos
charges qui étaient consacré à la
diffusion nous avions une charge de
personnel qui représentait 11 % de nos
charges
totales on avait des redevances versées
aux organismes de gestion collective
pour les auteurs les compositeurs et
cetera qui représentaient 5 % et qu'on
sort du coup de grille parce que c'est
pas
directement de l'argent qu'on verse au
producteurs mais on le verse à des org
de gestion collective ensuite nous
avions des charges intr grroup pour 7 %
qui sont les services mutualisés que
nous utilisons que ce soit
l'informatique la comptabilité les
bâtiments et cetera au sein du groupe 4
% qui était des taxes et enfin 10 % de
charges
diverses du fonctionnement d'un d'une
entreprise
normale donc voilà pour vos deux
premières questions je pense les avoir
couvertes
ensuite sur comment on va faire à
l'avenir avec avec cette base là
bon nous encore une fois on pense que le
coup de grille est quelque chose
qu'aujourd'hui ont réussi à maîtriser
une audience mais Céline pourra vous les
détailler après où on a réussi à
augmenter notre audience sur en
particulier le public jeune concernant
Energie 12 et à maintenir un leadership
très très fort sur les femmes sur Chéry
25 et que ça nous permet d'avoir
euh sur
2022 un chiffre d'affaires qui compense
quasiment nos nos charges et on pense
que ces fondamentaux là on va réussir à
les
maintenir aije répondu à à l'ensemble ou
est-ce que vous voulez une précision sur
quelque
chose oui c'est vous vous confirmez que
vu le modèle économique de de de la
TNT qui s'impose au différents
éditeurs vous êtes dans l'obligation
d'essayer de réunir un public le plus
large possible et et donc d'avoir un un
format qui qui qui évolue vers des
chaînes plus généralistes et et moins
moins
thématique non pas tout à fait on pense
qu'il faut au contraire alors dans nos
métiers on
parle catégorie d'audience on parle
souvent des 4 ans et plus ou d'autres
catégories
d'audience on pense qu'au contraire une
chaîne comme nous ne doit pas faire une
course à une audience 4 ans et plus à la
puissance de l'audience parce que en
effet par rapport au coup de gris qui
nous contraint ce serait une course dans
laquelle on s'épuiserait on atteindrait
jamais une rentabilité donc on est
plutôt à chercher et ces deux dernières
années l'ont démontré des croissances de
nos audiences typiquement sur sur des
catégories d'audience comme les 25 49
comme les femmes plutôt que de chercher
une augmentation de nos audience
générale donc au cours des deux
dernières années on a plutôt stabilisé
notre audience qu'on appelle 4 plus et
augmenter année après année nos
audiences sur les en particulier les les
catégories 25 49 j'aime pas l'expression
mais elle est connue dans le marché de
la publicité la femme responsable des
achats de moins de 50 ans ce sont des
catégories pour Cherry 25 qui évidemment
voilà donc nous surtout on veut
pas aller faire une course à l'audience
4 ans et plus ce serait pas la bonne
stratégie de
rentabilisation dernière question en ce
qui me concerne ensuite je passerai la
la parole à Monsieur le rapporteur
est-ce que vous avez envisagé par le
passé de de vendre les chaînes energy 12
ou chiri 25 est-ce que vous avez
envisagé de vous retirer de la la TNT je
vais
laiss oui nous nous avons toujours comm
même en radio tout ça cherché à à
optimiser notre notre développement et
euh et c'est quelque chose qui est qui
est qui est assez assez constant dans
dans dans nos métiers comme dans
d'autres secteurs de l'économie
également bah de de regarder les options
on a été approché on a reçu plusieurs
offres des non se per des offres c'est
des marques d'intérêt non engageantes de
de différents groupes donc c'est quelque
chose de d'habituel de regarder
effectivement et et nous avions même
pris une banque d'affaires pour nous
accompagner la banque
Lazar parce que nous nous avions reçu
nous nous voulions que qu'on puisse nous
aider à examiner ces offres sur le plan
financier notamment euh et c'est pas
notre métier d'origine et donc nous
avons effectivement envisagé les
différentes solutions parce que c'est
vrai que au départ les pertes étaient
quand même quand on atteignait des
niveaux proches des 30 millions de
pertes par an c'est même si notre groupe
est prospère euh c'était c'était quand
même ça interpellait mais euh là comme
on vous le dit depuis plusieurs années
depuis 2 ans 3 ans nous nous sommes
vraiment nous voyons chaque
année l'approche de la de la zone
verte et donc
c'est on n'a pas donné suite à ces à ces
différentes propositions voilà
mais cela dit nous sommes
confiants je rappelle simplement
que j'ai été à l'origine de la création
de TV6 avec gaumon et publicisme ça
c'est un an très ancien en
1986 et euh nous avions une concession
de 18 ans bon n l' reprise au bout d'un
an et c'est
M6 qui était filiale de la CLT et puisè
bertsman qui a qui s'est substitué à TV6
et M6 dans un paysage de qu
chaînesulement fa rappeler qu'à l'époque
il n'y avait que quatre chaînes et bien
a mis de nombreuses années avant
d'atteindre l'équilibre he donc c'est un
métier très long c'est vrai que les les
les spectateurs ne modifient pas leurs
habitudes de consommation télévision
euh aussi aussi vite ça va plus vite en
radio mais en télévision c'est c'est des
habitudes lourdes et on change pas de
d'habit vraiment il faut attirer les les
les spectateurs avec des programmes
vraiment qui sont et les programmes
éidement les plus attirants sur ceux qui
coûte le plus cher mais malgré ça nous
arrivons à voir le le bout du tunnel qui
est proche et voilà et nous en sommes
satisfaits peut-être si vous me
permettez monsieur le Président à parler
effectivement de euh une division de nos
pertes en 6 ans pour être extrêmement
précis donc le GR le pôle télé perdait
28,5 millions en 2017 et - 4,5 millions
en 2022 donc c'est une division par 6 de
la perte en 5 ans voilà ce qui montre
bien effectivement cette tendance dont
vient de parler effectivement le
président sur en télé il faut du temps
mais on est aujourd'hui sur ce modèle
avec une réduction extrêmement
significative du niveau de de perte du
pôle télé donc encore une fois une
division par 6 en en 5 ans et on voit en
plus que ce mouvement il est continue je
ve dire ce n'est pas tout d'un coup en
2022 la perte elle a diminué non quand
vous prenez les résultats du pôle télé
vous avez cette tendance que l'on
retrouve au fil des années avec une
perte qui se rédu ce qui nous donne
effectivement ce sentiment de confiance
de la tendance sur laquelle on
s'inscrit
donc vous vous confirmez bien que vous
avez eu des non seulement des marques
d'intérêt mais mais des offres quel
était le montant de ces offres monsieur
le Président si je puux me permettre
juridiquement c'est ce sont des marques
d'intérêt ce sont des offres indicatives
non
engageantes pour une précision juridique
de la terminologie ce sont vraiment des
offres indicatives non engageantes non
contraignantes merci monsieur le
président
monsieur le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
merci à chacun d'entre vous pour vos
prises de parole comme ne l'a peut-être
pas signalé le le président à l'instant
mais non engageant ne signifie pas que
ce ne sont pas des marque d'intérêt donc
ça ne donne pas le montant donc si vous
pouviez nous préciser le montant cela
nous ça nous intéresse quand
même voilà pardon oui bien sûr vous
donner montants c'est important
effectivement malgré tout cette
précision une marque d'intérêt non
engageante on connaî effectivement la la
valeur des montants qui sont indiqués
dans ce tel type de marque d'intérêt je
veux dire c'est vraiment des offres
indicatives et c'est comme ça qu'il faut
les prendre donc on a eu effectivement
des des marques d'intérêt non
engageantes avec des valeurs indicatives
qui s'échelonnaient entre 115 et 300
millions
d'euros mais j'insiste il y a une grosse
différence diffence entre la valeur
qu'on voit dans des marques d'intérêt et
des valeurs que l'on peut retrouver
derrière lorsqu'on parle de
session je comprendrai que vous ne
vouliez pas détailler pour chaque chaque
groupe qui se serait qui aurait
manifesté son intérêt est-ce que vous
pourrez nous faire parvenir une liste de
ces marques d'intérêt et comme ça on
aura les montants précis
euh
donc je comprends la difficulté à
atteindre la rentabilité euh le fait est
que dans la candidature initiale de chz
RHD le le projet était d'atteindre la
l'équilibre
d'exploitation 4 années
après l'autorisation soit en 2016 de
fait on en est encore loin puisque même
si les coûts la réduction des coûts
semble-t-il permet de d'approcher la
zone verte comme vous nous le disiez on
l'a toujours pas atteint enfin vous
l'avez toujours pas atteint
euh est-ce que vous ne considérez pas
est-ce est-ce que d'où venait
l'optimisme de ces projections puisque
bon en réalité vous saviez déjà à
l'époque que les usag des des
téléspectateurs ne sont pas aussi
labiles que ceux des auditeurs
radio oui tout à fait ben moi d'abord je
suis un optimiste in guérissable et et
puis surtout c'est
que il il y avait pas de raison parce
que radio et télévision sont deux médias
très complémentaires
la radio est encore plus forte quand
elle quand sa régie peut commercialiser
sa régie commerciale peut commercialisé
des de la télé et on arrive avec une
offre puissante on parlait des 25 49
ans le group la première offre
commerciale de France sur les 25 49 ans
en radio et et donc l'apport de de de
nos chaînes sur les 25 49 ans aide aussi
à la vente de la de la radio donc c'est
très vertueux pour pour pour pour N
radio et pour nos télévisions alors
effectivement ça prend du temps là en
télévision c'est beaucoup plus lourd
parce que c'est un métier just variable
alors que la radio est un métier de coup
fixe et et et ça dépend évidemment des
sommes que vous investissez dans les
programmes mais je suis très très
confiant maintenant sur la sur
l'atteinte du du point d'équilibre à à
brève échéance je pense qu'on est on est
on est sur la bonne voie
h
oui et aussi cette perspective de
rentabilité à 4 ans était dans un
dossier de candidature en 2011
euh évidemment l'univers dans lequel on
a évolué depuis le 12 décembre 2012
début de l'émission est
extrêmement différent d'une part dans
cet appel à candidature bah on ne savait
pas qui allait êtreetenu donc l'univers
de concurrence des six nouvelles chaînes
de la TNT était inconnu derrière il y a
quand même eu des évolutions euh
systémique très très forte euh la part
de réception qui était faite à travers
des boîtiers ADSL n'était pas du tout
celle qui est aujourd'hui et d'un seul
coup les Français et ça c'était quelque
chose qui qui avait commencé mais dont
il était difficile d'imaginer la la la
profondeur l'offre élargie ce qu'on
appelait l'offre élargie à l'époque
c'était le CAPSAT et d'un seul coup
laadsl qui a pénétré tous les foyers
puis la fibre ont donné une offre
élargie à tout le monde il y a eu des
concentrations on a vu aussi euh
certains groupes historiques racheté euh
des chaînes qui s'étaient lancées en
2005 sur la TNT et puis je vous parlais
de la pénétration des boîtiers fa mais
derrière il y a aussi l'explosion des
usages qu'on appelle VOD ou
SVOD sur internet en 2011 oou on était
Netflix ou on était Amazon ou on
était souvenez-vous à l'époque on louait
des films sur des
portails en louant pour une soirée un
film donc on a des usages qui ont été
extrêmement différents ça probablement
contribuer en effet à cet écosystème qui
a été moins favorable à l'atteintte de
la rentabilité à 4 ans euh que Jean-Paul
décrivait comme l'optimisme qui pouvait
prévaloir en 2011
ou euh a a mis je crois 7 ans avant
d'atteindre l'équilibre à leur création
et et dans un paysage qui ne comptait
que quatre chaînes en clair c'est c'est
quand même faut faut faut le signaler et
il y avait pas Internet il y avait pas
les plateformes comme Netflix et cetera
donc c'était bien plus facile et ils ont
mis de mémoire à peu près plusieurs
années près de 7 ans avant de parvenir à
la à la
rentabilité merci beaucoup euh pour
qu'on se comprenne bien moi vous savez
je j'ai peu de souci de de la
rentabilité de votre déchet c'est pas
mon propos ce qui est mon propos c'est
de savoir si votre optimisme aujourd'hui
est mieux fondé que celui que vous
manifestiez dans la candidature de 2012
donc en l'occurrence vous m'expliquez
que M6 a mis 7 ans à devenir rentable
vous le saviez déjà quand vous aviez
quand vous avez candidaté donc le
paysage lui était changeant vous auriez
pu euh faire une une motiver votre
candidature avec des projections plus
proches de la réalité c'est ça qui
m'intéresse je serai le maître du monde
là si j' arrivé mais cela dit
euh je je suis très confiant encore une
fois nous app cochon de la zone verte et
et c'est vrai que bon on a été on a mis
du temps on a été patient mais la
télévisioncore une fois ça je l'ai
découvert c'est un métier de longue très
longue haleine
VO
merci parmi les éléments donc de la
stratégie de rentabilisation des
audiences c'est ce que vous annonciez en
2022 et l'expression que vous employez
vous évoquez la réduction de vos charges
notamment de votre coût de grille donc
ce que je comprends de cette réduction
de coût de grille c'est que évidemment
c'est la nature des programmes qui est
impacté et donc la question qui se pose
c'est comment se concilie l'exigence de
rentabilité et la qualité des programmes
proposés alors oui cet équilibre il
repose en effet sur des arbitrages qui
doivent concilier la maîtrise du coup de
grille
inévitablement ce qui ce qui n'est pas
un un choix qualitatif c'est on doit
être prudent et ciblé sur les programmes
qu'on achète et en particulier ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est par rapport
à une catégorie d'audience qu'on cherche
sur les chaînes à titre d'exemple par
exemple sur les cette catégorie
2549 on est passé de 2021 à 2023 de 2,4
à 2,7 points d'audience sur sur le pôle
sur et encore une fois pardon pour
l'expression cette femme responsable des
achat de moins de 50 ans nous sommes
passés de 2,8 à 3 points d'audience dans
le même temps et j'ai pas le chiffre
sous les yeux mais céine là probablement
mais c'est parce que c'est encore une
fois c'est un chiffre qui ne nous
préoccupe pas au quotidien notre
audience 4+ elle a dû stagner voire
baisser de 01 point je j'ai un petit
doute donc c'est cette stratégie
d'audience qui nous a permis de réduire
le coup de grille en retirant certains
programmes qui pouvaient être onéreux
pour générer une audience plutôt de
l'ordre des 4 plus qui ne nous
permettait pas de rentabiliser et au
contraire d'aller faire des choix
éditeur
pointu sur des catégories d'audience qui
nous permettaient de nous différencier
quand on est une petite chaîne comme
nous on peut pas aller lutter sur les
audiences 4 plus avec les énormes
chaînes avec les groupes historiques qui
sont dans les gammes de 10 15 20 %
d'audience pour une chaîne 30 % pour un
groupe il faut pas que nous on aille
lutter sur ce territoire là faut qu'on
aille lutter sur des publics très en
affinité avec la ligne éditoriale et
avec l'ADN du groupe qui est le
divertissement et les femmes et c'est C
C équilibre là qu'on a réussi à trouver
depuis quelques années et qui nous amène
en 2022 à à à à ce point de de
satisfaction on espérant que 2023 voilà
mais je ne sais pas mais 2022 c'est
cette logique là c'est pas ça pas été un
sacrifice qualitatif sur les programmes
ça a été vraiment un ciblage des
programmes en se
disant qu'est-ce qu'on veut comme
audience qu'est-ce qui fait que cette
audience là on saura la monétiser pour
se payer le coup de grille et c'est
c'est une recherche que les équipes de
Céline font au qu quand on va acquérir
des droits sur le marché c'est vraiment
ça notre préoccupation c'est c'est pas
d'aller le matin nous quand céine
regarde les audiences avec ses équipe
encore une fois le chiffre qu'on va
regarder c'est pas le 4 plus on sait
qu'on va pas on sait qu'on va pas battre
TF1 en 4 plus on sait qu'on va pas
battre C8 en 4 plus ou ça nous arrive
une fois dans l'année d'être numéro 4 ou
5 en 4 plus c'est pas notre objectif
notre objectif c'est vraiment d'être sur
des audiences dont on sait qu'elles vont
faire la singularité et on a quand même
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
téléspectateurs qui tous les soirs de
l'ordre de 300 par 300000 à peu près par
chaîne qui viennent nous regarder c'est
bien parce qu'on leur offre quelque
chose de particulier et c'est ça qui
nous permettra de d'atteindre je
l'espère l'équilibre dans dans dans un
avenir
proche bien merci je crois qu'on on
comprend la la
stratégie simple observation j'ai du mal
à considérer que on soit thématique
si on s'intéresse à la moitié de
l'humanité les femmes et à supposer que
les hommes ne s'intéressent pas non plus
aux femmes mais voilà c'estun incise euh
sur ce qui est de la le contenu lui-même
la programmation de nergie 12 et ché 25
bénéficie évidemment de la synergie des
deux chaînes j'imagine euh de la
circulation des programmes quelle est la
part de rediffusion et de production
inédite dans la composition de vos
grilles euh notamment pour les GES
dominants alors je vais laisser Céline
répondre sur ces sujets éditoriaux et
bien sûr je compléterai le K
alors sur votre double question sur la
circulation des programmes entre nos
deux chaînes il y en a effectivement ça
participe à la programmation de nos
chaînes mais ça reste extrêmement limité
euh en 2022 sur energy 12 les programmes
communs avec ch25 ont représenté 483
heur à l'année hors publicité et hors
téléachat donc ça représente 1h30 par
jour soit 25,5 % du temps d'antenne 5,5
5,5 pardon sur chér 25 en 2022 toujours
les programmes communs avec Energie 12
on représenté
1339h de programme toujours hors
téléachat et publicité soit 3h30 par
jour en moyenne et 15,3 % du temps
d'antenne mais ceux-ci sont diffusés à
des heures principalement
creuses donc la grande majorité des
programmes de nos chaînes restent propre
à chacune de ces chaînes chacune de nos
chaînes a une programmation singulière
une ligne éditoriale qui est propre et
dans le respect de son format et de ses
conventions c'est ce qui permet de
différencier vraiment nos deux chaînes
et il suffit d'ailleurs de se rapporter
au au au bilan à l'étude d'impact Parton
de la de l'arcom qui l'ont publié au
mois de janvier dernier et qui montre
très bien que le profil de nos
téléspectateurs entre nos deux chaînes
est très distincte comme l'a dit
plusieurs fois Hervé sur energy 12 nous
avons le public un des publics les plus
jeunes de la TNT et sur sherf 25 un
public plus âgé mais le plus féminin de
la TNT
ensuite sur la la part de nos
obligations d'inédit sur les la
production
d'inédit sur chérry 25 on a une
obligation conventionnelle de diffusion
de programme inédit qui est de 365 heur
par an la définition de
l'inédit via notre convention c'est la
première diffusion sur toutes les
chaînes gratuites de la TNT cette
obligation comprend la durée de notre
première diffusion plus plus les
rediffusions éventuelles sous 30 jours
en 2022 ch25 a diffusé 441 he de de
programmes inédits dans le cadre de
cette obligation sur Energie 12 nous
n'avons pas d'obligation conventionnelle
sur la diffusion de programmes inédits
mais on a tout de même essayé de vous
l'estimer justement pour pour vous pour
vous étayer des chiffres donc toujours
dans cette optique de première diffusion
sur la chaîne avec les éventuelle
rediffusion sur 30 jours en en 2022 on
estime à 2450 he de Programm inédit en
première diffusion et particulièrement
1660 heures d'inédit sur le
divertissement qui est la singularité de
Energie 12 je je reprécise bien que pour
Energie 12 comme nous n'avons pas
d'obligation conventionnell c'est des
chiffres qui n'ont pas été publiés dans
nos bilans avec l'arcom ce sont vraiment
des
estimations pour être bien certain de
comprendre le calcul de l'inedit c'est
donc on considère que l'inedit et est-ce
qu'il est recompté jeis le reformuler
comme ça est-ce qu'il est recomté
lorsque il est rediffusé sous 30 jours
et est-ce que dans le chiffre des 441
heur il faut défalquer si j'ose dire le
les éventuels doublons s'il y a une
rediffusion sous
3 c'est exactement ça c'est vraiment la
première diffusion qui permet de
décomter la la notion d'inédit et toutes
les diffusions qui seront faites les
rediffusions qui seront faites sous un
délai de 30
jours donc je précise ma question sur
les 40 441 heur en question est-ce que
vous êtes capable de décomposer et de me
dire quelle est la part de passage
unique et quelle est la part de passage
doublé ou triplé je sais
pas alors c'est une précision qu'il
faudra qu'on vous apporte ultérieurement
on n'est pas capable de la sortir ici
juste pour bien resituer la logique
d'acquisition de droit nous quand on
achète des droits qu'il soit sur des les
fictions les vres audiovisuelles on
achète ce qu'on appelle des
multidiffusions donc en fait on va
acheter typiquement quatre ou six
multidiffusions une multidiffusion étant
composée d'un passage et d'un autre
nombre de passages souvent 4 ou
5 dans les 30 jours qui suivent ça c'est
ce qu'on appelle une multidiffusion et
là dans le calcul qu'on a fait en effet
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur le
rapporteur ce que nous demande de faire
comme communication l'arcom dans nos
bilans annuel ce qui concerne Cherry 25
c'est bien le volume de la première
multidiffusion donc si on le diffuse 5
fois une œuvre qui durerait 1 heure va
compter 5 he puisqu'on l'a exposé 5 fois
en 30
jours si si je vous ai bien écouté on a
un nombre d'heur d'inédit pour ennergie
12 qui est beaucoup plus important que
pour ch
alors le chiffre qu'on a communiqué est
en effet plus important mais ce sont
deux définitions différentes qu'il y a
une définition convention dans notre
convention qui lit ché 25 avec LARCOM
pour Chéry 25 nous n'en avons pas pour
nergie 12 donc on a pour essayer de
répondre le plus précisément à votre
question sur nnergie 12 on a
pris c'est pas par rapport aux
diffusions c'est par rapport à c'est
quoi un inédit là on a considéré sur
energy 12 que ce qui était inédit c'est
la première fois que energy 12 diffusait
ce contenu contrairement à la règle
conventionnelle qui est sur Cherry 25
qui est la première fois que ce contenu
est exposer en TNT
voilà on peut si si vous le souhaitez là
aussi mais honnêtement c'est on a passé
beaucoup de temps à à traiter les bases
de données ces derniers jours pour
essayer de sortir le chiffre parce que
il y a ceux qui sont dans nos bilans bah
ça on a des processus qui font qu'on les
sort tous les mois pour alimenter nos
bilan puis il y a les chiffres qui ne
sont pas dans nos bilan et typiquement
savoir sur nergie 12 c'est pour ça qu'on
a' pas pu le calculer je n'ai pas moins
l'information dans notre base de données
de savoir si ce contenu a déjà été
exposé par une autre chaîne de la TNT ça
je je le sais pas donc contrairement à
Chéry 25 quand on acquiert un contenu on
se pose la question puisqu'on sait qu'on
va avoir l'obligation de déclare àarcom
donc on se pose la question au
distributeur ou au producteur de dire
est-ce qu'il a déjà été diffusé en TNT
il nous le dit on coche une cause dans
une base de données derrière on fait un
reporting facile sur égie dou j'ai pas
cette information là donc c'est pour ça
qu'on vous a communiqué celle-ci non
parce qu'il y a pas d'obligation voilà
c'est ça donc encore une fois si vous
nous laissez quelques semaines on
pourrait apporter cette
précision merci beaucoup a priori si
vous n'y êtes pas obligé il y a pas de
raison que on soit plus royaliste plus
je comprends il y a pas de raison
vraiment qu'on soit plus royaliste que
le roi et donc on ne mettra pas
forcément vos équipes à contribution
dessus la question qui se pose c'est
pourquoi l'arcom aura estimé utile de
poser une
condition de diffusion d'inédit pour
Cherry 25 et pas pour pour Energie 12 à
moins que ce ne soit l'inverse et ça
peut-être vous êtes en mesure de me
répondre c'est vous qui avez avait dans
la la candidature évoquer le la
possibilité des inédit plutôt que
l'arcom puisque autant que je sache les
l'appel la candidature de de l'arcom ne
portait pas de de
critère non honnêtement je je sais pas
répondre j'étais pas en poste dans le
groupe à l'époque des dossiers de
candidature donc ça demandera là aussi à
à à regarder ce qu'on avait mis dans No
dossiers de candidature ou ouais
ouaisess ouais ok ouais faut qu'on
regarde les dossiers de candidature
est-ce que c'était des propositions
spontanées qu'on a fait dans les
dossiers de candidature ou pas
honnêtement je incapable de de le dire
de
tête merci beaucoup euh joui ce sera
intéressant de de voir si c'est l'arcom
qui a proposé ou a a suggéré des des
critères ou si c'était spontané euh pour
rentrer un peu dans le détail des des
obligations spécifiques d'éergie 12 une
en particulier et marquante euh les
clips musicaux figuraient parmi les
genres qui devaient principalement
composer l'offre de le programme et en
réalité il n'en a plus été diffusé à
partir d'août 2008 euh malgré les
regrets du CSA à l'époque comment
avez-vous obtenu que le régulateur
finalement supprime cette exigence dans
votre convention à l'occasion de la
reconduction de votre autorisation en
2019 alors je me permets d'apporter une
petite précision y compris dans la
convention initiale d'énernergie dou ce
n'était pas une exigence c'était un des
types de programmes qui étaient listés
mais sur lequel il n'y avait pas
d'exigence ou de quotas de diffusion
donc
euh energy 12 n'a jamais été
conventionné par le CSA en son temps
comme une chaîne musicale c'était un des
gens qui était diffusable sur la chaîne
et encore une fois si on essaie de se
replacer dans un contexte il y a bientôt
20 ans en 2005 pour des chaînes qui se
lançaient sur la TNT d'un réseau TNT qui
ne couvrait pas encore 97 % de la
population française qui avait une
montée en charge aussi sur le le réseau
de diffusion diffuser des vidéoclips euh
surtout quand on est une chaîne qui
s'appelle énergie 12 ça avait du sens
euh mais euh il y a plein d'usages qui
ont changé et en particulier là aussi
l'arrivée d'Internet au bout de quelques
années
souvenez-vous ça a été quand même parmi
les premier contenu que tout le monde a
été qu'on a commencé à pouvoir voir de
la vidéo souvenez-vous avec les les
modems qui qui faisait du bruit quand on
se connectait sur Internet et qui nous
coûtait cher ça a été les premiers genes
qu'on a été voir qui ont été disponibles
qui ont été mis parce que c'était des
format cours et que c'était à l'époque
quasi impossible pour des questions
économiques ou techniques de regarder un
longmétrage sur Internet ces formats
cours étaient consommés donc pour nous
il est apparu à la fois on va dire un
manque de singularité de ce contenu qui
devenait disponible sur d'autres réseaux
et puis
euh les vidéoclips sur une chaîne ça
crée pas une audience
euh très très forte donc on a préféré
investir sur d'autres types de
programmes de la fiction des divertis
voilà ensuite comme vous le disiez en
2020 quand on a renégocié la Convention
on a échangé avec le CSA
pour voir si on pouvait retirer de cette
liste de programmes qui était qui
n'était pas exhaustive et qui n'était
pas une obligation si on pouvait la
retirer le CSA en a convenu on en
diffusait plus toutefois on a quand même
le CSA nous a maintenu une obligation en
disant si vous diffusez des vidéoclips
donc on a toujours la possibilité de le
faire he c'est encore une fois ce
n'était pas un jur obligatoire ça ne
l'est toujours pas on l'a juste retiré
de la liste des programmes si demain on
diffuse des vidéoclips on garde un
engagement de diffuser je prends mes
notes pour pas dire de bêtises 20 % de
la programmation de vidéo musique
d'expression française et de nouveaux
talents ou de nouvelles production donc
on a dit ok si demain on a un concept on
a une émission voilà nous ou un
producteur qui vient sur nos antennes
avec des vidéoclip on aura quand même
cet engagement de évidemment on garde
l'obligation euh car 30 60 européens
expression française mais en plus on
aura 20 % dédiés aux jeunes
talent merci beaucoup eu le CSA toujours
dans la pour Energie 12 le CSA avait
regretté à plusieurs reprises le manque
de diversité du traitement de la vie
culturelle et des loisirs et le peu de
temps d'antenne accordé à ce sujet son
cela figure notamment dans les rapports
de 2018 et 2019 euh quel traitement
avez-vous réservé à à ce signalement
dans la mesure où vous nous expliquez
que nergy 12 est une chaîne de
divertissement on peut imaginer que la
culture participe au divertissement et
que la diversité des approches
culturelles participerait aussi au
divertissement alors on a effectivement
accepté de renforcer cette disposition
avec notre nouvelle convention
applicable au 1er janvier 2020 et on y a
aussi apporté un complément un
renforcement en en appliquant une place
particulière aux jeunes talent de la
musique en 2020 et 2021 avec la crise
sanitaire liée au covid les
manifestations culturelles en ont été
impacté et donc la programmation de
énergie Douge en a été aussi impactée en
ce sens néanmoins en 2020 Energie 12 a
lancé un nouveau programme inédit
intitulé Energie instant live animé par
WF et c'est consacré c'est un programme
qui est consacré au jeunes talents de la
musique c'est un un programme plutôt
simple qui accueille un invité musical
sous la forme d'une interview et ensuite
il y a une une interprétation d'un de
ces morceaux en live sur l'année 2022 on
a on a diffusé 46 numéros différents de
ce programme-là on a accueilli notamment
dernièrement Nui incolor et d de Preto
donc avec les sénnergie de la radio on
arrive justement à à renforcer ce ce
côté cette place particulière aux jeunes
talents de la musique par ailleurs on
diffuse également toujours le programme
Energy 12m qui traite de l'actualité
musicale et cinéma matographique et
également aussi des spectacles d'humour
on a aussi dernièrement accès aussi au
niveau musical avec Vita avec le le
groupe kyot également donc voilà c'est
encore aussi des programmes qui
permettent aussi de mettre en en avant
l'actualité musicale du moment et enfin
depuis 2022 Energie 12 propose un
programme totalement inédit qui est les
MASTER du rire qui est un spectacle
vivant événementiel comme le disait
Hervé en introduction c'est donne une
carte blanche à de jeunes humoristes
naissants ou confirmés qui viennent
performer du coup un sketch de 8 à 10
minutes sur la scène de l'Apollo théâtre
on a déjà proposé quatre éditions depuis
fin 2022 et on prépare deux nouvelles
éditions qui seront diffusé au courant
du du premier semestre 2024 et ces
jeunes talents aussi humoristes ont par
ailleurs une actualité quand ils
participent au Master du rire ils ont
par ailleurs une actualité à côté je
peux citer Cécile mar qui a son
spectacle cru au théâtre Saint-Martin
Alexis le rossignol qui est en tourné
actuellement avec son spectacle Le sens
de la vie qu'il avait par ailleurs rodé
à l'Européen on avait Taric aussi qui a
participé au Master du rire et qui avait
aussi son spectacle vérité qui jouait
aussi à l'Apollo théâtre et enfin romain
dodwick qui jouait adorable au palais au
Petit Palais des Glaces donc c'est aussi
un programme qui renforce aussi cette
disposition du traitement de de de de
l'actualité culturelle et puis enfin de
manière un petit peu plus marginal on
diffuse aussi on essaie de coller aussi
à l'actualité culturelle je prends pour
exemple quand milen Farmer a réalisé
plusieurs concerts en Stade de France en
juin dernier cette semaine là on a
consacré un documentaire à cet artiste
là en première partie de soirée sur
Energie 12 donc voilà ça permet aussi de
faire un lien avec l'actualité
culturelle et une petite précision sur
les Masters du rire c'est une production
don on très fier puisque c'est on l'a
fait on la programme c'est nous qui
choisissons les artistes et c'est exposé
en première partie de soirée c'est pas
quelque chose qui est en fond de grille
ou autre c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui pour nous est emblématique de de de
l'ADN du groupe si je peux me permettre
c'est en partenariat avec rire et
chanson merci euh pour essayer d'être
très exhaustif sur ce sujet est-ce que
les les les émissions dont vous nous
avez parlé sont des rendez-vous
réguliers parce que moi je ne suis qu'un
béoien et je consulte les magazines et
euh
je ne vois pas un événement régulier qui
serait une émission musicale culturelle
spécifique je
vois des des séries avec H épisodes
d'affilés mais je ne vois pas de
rendez-vous
culturel grand public ou ou même un peu
pointu je sais
pas alors sur sur les programmes
télévision que vous avez montré vous
avez pas forcément l'exhaustivité de
notre programmation par exemple Energie
instant live est diffusé le samedi matin
tous les samedi du matin à 9h30 ensuite
pour les Masters du rire ça c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est une
production qui est qui est difficile
entre guillemets à mettre en place
puisque il faut qu'on aille chercher de
jeunes talents des artistes donc il faut
que nos équipes aillent voir pas mal de
spectacles de standup à Paris pour faire
cette programmation donc c'est pour ça
qu'on peut pas se permettre on aimerait
pouvoir en présenter davantage dans
notre grille mais c'est un programme qui
est qui est important pour nous à faire
et dont on la programmation notamment
des jeunes artistes est très importante
pour nous il faut aussi les convaincre
de venir se présenter euh en prime time
sur energy 12 donc c'est un travail de
longue Aline et on préfère privilégier
le temps de bien préparer ses émissions
pour offrir le meilleur programme
possible mais c'est quand même un un
très beau programme qu'on puisse
proposer en en première partie de soirée
ce que ce qu' font pas forcément nos
concurrents donc ennergie instant live
samedi matin
9h30 c'est pas ce que je vais mais bon
c'est la chaîne qui fait VO je il faud
faudra que je regarde les programmes
évidemment je peux pas regarder la
totalité mais vous feriez bien
d'informer les les éditeurs de
presse pour ce qui est de Cherry
25 la prog la convention prévoit une
programmation composée majoritairement
de magazin et de documentaires alors
l'obligation est respectée toutefois la
répartition entre magazine et
documentaire pose question puisque le
magazine représente 99 et5i pour et euh
les documentaires 0,5 % de ces deux
genres dominants est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas comme moi que la formulation
composé majoritairement de magazines et
de documentaires laisse plutôt penser
queon aura une par une parité euh de
genre euh entre les entre les
deux alors effectivement les chiffres
que vous venez d'indiquer sont pour
l'année 2020 euh mais cette mais cette
cet indicatif je a fluctué quand même
pendant des années si je suis si je
prends une année un petit peu plus
récente l'année 2022 en l'occurrence
nous étions à 28 % de documentairire et
72 % de
magazine et peut-être
pardon précision he
sur la répartition documentaire magazine
euh c'est on peut par exemple acquérir
un documentaire et si on fait un plateau
de lancement pour contextualiser un
documentaire ça devient un magazine dans
dans dans les classifications étant
donné que nous nous n'avons pas de
sous-compartiment dans notre quota entre
magazine et documentaire voilà on peut
des fois déclarer on a trouvé d'autres
exemples si jamais ça vous intéresse
mais nous on peut avoir des choses c'est
c'est pas une classification qui est
absolue voilà et comme nous on va pas
honnêtement peut-être qu'il y a des
années où on a déclaré un peu trop dans
un genre ou dans un autre genre parce
que voilà on fait 60 secondes de
lancement sur un plateau avec un
présentateur ou un journaliste qui va
expliquer le contexte du documentaire
qui est derrière ça devient un magazine
voilà pour
information si bien que après la le
rappel à l'Endre j'ai envie de dire de
de l'arcom si c'est un rappel à l'ordre
en tout cas le signalement de la que
l'arcom avait fait sur ce sujet euh vous
avez peut-être pu
chercher à rentrer dans le détail et à
distinguer entre C ces genrees de format
ou ou ù c'est vraiment l'effet d'une
stratégie différente vous avez décidé
d'acquérir plus de plus de documentaires
qu'auparavant alors non en aucun cas
c'est une volonté
de jouer sur les chiffres encore une
fois notre obligation c'est un genre
majoritaire document plus magazine donc
notre obligation et ce sur quoi l'arcom
pourrait venir c'est sur la somme des
deux donc jouer sur l'un plutôt que
l'autre c'est pas notre sens non c'est
aussi encore une fois on est sur un
marché d'acquisition de droit et de
production un petit peu qui fait que
quand on acquiert quelque chose on se
pose la question de se dire comment on
va le mieux l'exposer il y a des
documentaires qui pardon de l'expression
tiennent tout seul on va les diffuser
tout va bien et il y a des documentaires
sur lesquels on estime qu'un plateau de
lancement qu'on peut réaliser
nous-mêmees ça a été le cas sur un
certain nombre d'émissions ce plateau de
lancement va enrichir le programme et du
coup on le fait donc c'est c'est quand
même très dépendant du contenu qu'on va
acheter et le coût de production de l'un
et de l'autre magazine
documentaire on se situe comment l'un
est beaucoup plus cher que l'autre
beaucoup
moins alors pas forcément en fait ça
dépend ça dépend surtout enfin de
plusieurs critères en fait les les prix
que ça soit des prix d'acquisition ou de
pré-achat il varie en fonction de la
durée en fonction du lieu de la
complexité du tournage en fonction des
intervenants en fonction s'il y a des
images d'archiv ou non donc pour vous
donner euh un un un ordre d'idée sur
l'année 2022- 2023 à titre indicatif sur
de l'acquisition ou du pré-achat de
magazine ou de documentaire nous étions
sur une fourchette allant de 40000 €
jusqu'à 95000 €. et pour l'acquisition
entre quatre multidiffusion si c'est de
l'acquisition et on peut monter jusqu'à
8 multidiffusion si c'est du pré-achat
mais après nous on produit peu
effectivement directement on fait appel
soit à des producteurs pour du pré-achat
soit auprès de distributeurs pour de
l'acquisition donc on n' pas forcément
euh une vision globale des coûts de
production précis de de de ces
programmes
là
merci
sur les les les rappels à l'ordre si je
puux dire de de l'arcom sur les C
derniers exercices 2018-2022 le csacom
est intervenu à quatre reprises
concernant un programme particulier
crime avec ces différentes déclinaisons
en avril 2018 en mai 2018 en juin 2019
et en mars 2022 euh la première fois il
s'agissait de d'évoquer l'obligation
d'honnêeté et de rigueur dans
l'utilisation des images la deuxième
fois le respect des droits de la
personne notamment le droit au respect
de la vie privée le respect des
dispositions de l'article 3 de la
délibération du 18 avril relative à
l'honnêteté et à l'indépendance de
l'information et des programmes et le 30
mars 2022 la dernière fois sur le
respect des préconisations adressé aux
éditeurs en janvier 2013 concernant
l'évocation des affaires judiciaires
pour ces différents donc on voit là
qu'on a un sujet assez récurrent sur ce
programme euh quelle disposition a été
prise depuis et pourquoi n'ont pas
ét-elle prise auparavant apparemment euh
pour que l'arcom nait plus à à vous
rappeler à
l'ordre
ah ça y est bon euh donc comme vous
l'avez dit c'estes lettres de rappel ou
de mise en garde était consacré à crime
et la mise en demeure de 23 du 23 mai
2018 était consacré à crime effet divers
la quotidienne en direct euh donc déjà
l'émission en direct euh que nous avions
en quotidien n'existe plus depuis le
juin 2022 euh et le programme crime lui
nous n'en avons plus commandé depuis au
moins 18 mois ou 2 ans c'est l'ordre
d'idée donc aujourd'hui on diffuse un
stock que nous avions acquis euh il y a
quelques années et comme il nous reste
des multidiffusions et comme toute
entreprise qui a un stock on continue à
en diffuser aujourd'hui sur cher25 plus
du tout sur Energie 12 mais oui en effet
l'arcom nous avait fait des remarques
sur ces sur ces programmes donc bien
évidemment à chaque fois on s'efforce de
prendre en compte avec la plus grande
attention chacune des interventions de
l'arcom à chaque fois sur les cas qui
ont été cité nous les avons transmises
au producteurs he puisque nous n'étions
le diffuseur mais il y avait un
producteur sur ces contenus là et à
chaque fois euh que ça a été nécessaire
ça a donné lieu à des modifications du
programme s'il y avait encore des
rediffusions de ce programme qui pouvait
exister
euh la la pour la dernière qui date de
Mar 2022 il n'y a pas de manquement
particulier on a eu une lettre de rappel
euh et je crois que ça consistait en la
modification d'un prénom et c'est
quelque chose que nous avons fait donc
pour vous donner un petit peu la nature
il y a une fois un
floutage qui nous a été euh on va pas
dire conseillé mais voilà il y avait
potentiellement c'était des images
d'archives que nous avions acheté à une
chaîne public national qui avait traité
d'un d'un cas judiciaire voilà il a
quelqu qu s'en est plein trouvant que le
floutage n'était pas suffisant il a été
refait et une fois où un prénom était
cité et nous avons avec le producteur
modifier le contenu afin de modifier le
le prénom encore une fois ces programmes
la quotidienne n'existe plus sur notre
antaine depuis fin juin 2022 et crime
estant sur chér 25 plus sur Energie 12
voilà on estime que c'est des programmes
qui justement par rapport au
repositionnement éditorial qu'on
évoquait aux cibles je dirais d'audience
au catégories d'audience qu'on cherche
c'est voilà quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui a plutôt tendance à être
moins présent sur nos
merci si bien que la question qui qui me
vient à l'esprit et quelle cible
visiez-vous avec un programme comme
celui-ci alors c'est des programmes qui
justement marchent très bien fautut faut
jamais oublier hein pardon je vais
essayer de le caricat pas de le car
quiur mais de le simplifier une audience
c'est la multiplication le facteur d'un
nombre de personnes par une durée
euh c'est des programmes qui sur des
cibles plus âgées à l'heure o auquel ils
étaient diffusés faisaient ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure de l'audience 4
ans et plus c'était des programmes
générateurs de puissance qui fait que le
lendemain matin qu'on regarde nos
audiences c'est des programmes qui font
de l'audience voilà en 4+ parce que
quand on fait une émission la
quotidienne qui était à 12h 30 ou voilà
à 12h30
bah c'est une typologie de public qui
voilà va prendre 1 heure 1 heure et demi
et rester devant la télévision à C Hel
et ça ça fait de la puissance et
aujourd'hui ça ne correspond plus tout à
fait à notre stratégie comme je l'ai
évoqué en début de de
session donc pour être clair dans dans
votre logique vous choisissez de
sacrifier d'une certaine façon un
programme qui fait de la puissance comme
vous dites au bénéfice de programme qui
permettent d'être plus homogène d'avoir
un public plus homogène plus tout au
long de la
journée je dirais pas plus homogène mais
en tout cas oui dans nos choix
aujourd'hui alors c'est des mouvements
longs encore une fois parce que bah il y
a des habitudes de consommation il y a
des stocks de de contenu que nous avons
mais oui aujourd'hui on essaie d'avoir
dans notre choix de programme une
affinité sur nergie 12 auprès des
publics jeunes et d'ailleurs Energie 12
un est l'une des seules chaînes de la
TNT au cours des trois dernières années
j'ai plus le chiffre en tête on a passé
de 56 ans à 50 ans voilà quand quand la
TNT a vieilli je crois de presque 2 ans
Energie 12 a rajonni de 3 ans donc c
cette stratégie qu'on évoque elle est
validée par le public on voit bien qu'on
a un public jeune et qui plus est parce
qu'il y a deux façons d'avoir une
audience plus jeune c'est soit en en
perdant on va dire les plus anciens de
de nos audiences non au contraire on a
réussi à ramener des jeunes devant la
télévision donc voilà ça pour nous c'est
quelque chose qui est important et c'est
ça qui nous permet per de développer
cette stratégie de renbilisation et sur
Cherry 25 c'est toujours aller adresser
le public le plus féminin possible et si
vous regardez encore une fois dans
l'étude d'impact économique qu' a publié
l'arcom en décembre chéri 25 70 % de
public féminin très loin devant toutes
les autres chaînes sur cette cible
là merci je vais vous poser une question
qui va devenir peut-être j'espère un
rituel dans cette commission d'enquête
euh comment déf
définiriez-vous la télévision idéale et
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que la qualité
en
télévision je je je crois qu'on ne peut
pas répondre à cette question je pense
pas qu'il y a une
réponse je pense que ce qui fait la
richesse de la TNT c'est sa pluralité et
que chaque Français a le droit de
répondre par lui-même à cette question
et de trouver la qualité qui lui va je
consoite tout à fait que pour certains
la qualité puisse être un très beau
documentaire
sur hararté et que pour d'autres la
qualité c'est s'asseoir devant la
télévision passer un bon moment de
détente je je je ne me permettrait pas
de répondre de
façon doctrinaire à à à qu'est-ce que
c'est que la qualité nous notre métier
c'est d'offrir à un certain public un
bon moment on est un métier de
divertissement nous en particulierers
sur nos chaînes ce qu'on veut c'est que
les Français quand il quand ils
s'assoient et qui nous font l'honneur de
regarder nos chaînes qu'il passe un bon
moment voilà et je ne dis pas que c'est
ça la qualité et que ce que har fait
quand il diffuse un très beau magazine
ce n'est pas de la qualité c'est une
qualité extraordinaire qu'ils peuvent
diffuser à un public qui a envie de voir
ça à un moment donné donc je ne pense
pas qu'il soit en tout cas moi je ne me
permettrai pas de répondre à à c'est
quoi la qualité il y a autant de qualité
que il y a de français ou d'habitants
sur le territoire national qui vont
regarder ces contenus là et chacun a le
droit de mettre la qualité là où il le
veut
du coup je vais décliner cette question
sous un autre format
euh on je ne sais pas si vous avez des
enfants on va postuler que vous en
auriez est-ce que vous laisseriez vos
enfants regarder la chaîne que vous que
vous produisez euh combien de temps par
jour par exemple euh et à partir de quel
âge alors oui
euh je je je suis même euh
alors ils sont un peu trop Pagés
aujourd'hui par rapport à certains
programmes qu'on diffuse mais oui je
serais plutôt très enclin et plutôt très
fier de les voir regarder certains
programmes qu'on diffuse après encore
une fois bon aujourd'hui ce sont des
jeunes adultes euh ils font leur choix
et c'est très bien comme ça dans un
paysage qui est très diverse mais oui si
votre question est de savoir
si je serais inquiè de mettre mes
enfants devant 12 ou ch 25 non en aucun
cas il n'y a aucun programme que nous
diffusons aujourd'hui sur lequel je me
dirais pourvu que mes enfants ne le
voient pas à aucun
moment je je ne vais pas soumettre
chacun d'entre vous à cette question qui
est
anecdotique une dernière question sans
doute si le président
m'autorise il y a la question évidemment
du renouvellement des autorisations qui
se profil pour l'une des deux chaînes
euh est-ce que vous pourriez nous
confirmer Queen 2000 11 lorsque le
groupe a déposé trois dossiers de
candidature pour l'attribution de six
chaînes le CSA a demandé de préciser
lequel de ces dossiers était
prioritaire merci monsieur le rapporteur
alors nous avons nous avions
effectivement présenté trois projets
différents my energy Nostal à télé et
Cherry HD et pour être précis nous avons
revisionné les auditions publiques de
l'époque parce qu'on s'en rappelait plus
et lors des auditions publi pour les
dossiers ma Energie le 5 mars 2012
Nostal àélé le 12 mars 2012 et Cherry HD
le 14 mars 2012 la question de la
priorité a été posée par des conseillers
effectivement à l'époque du CSA et ainsi
que le président Michel Boyon ce que
nous avions répondu c'était que nous
croyons bien sûr beaucoup à nos trois
projets que nous aimions nos trois
projets mais que le projet HD Chéry HD
pardon était le dossier prioritaire et
notamment complémentaire et si vous me
le permettez monsieur le rapporteur plus
précisément lors de l'audition de Nostal
à télé du 12 mars
2012 le président du CSA a posé la
question suivante à la lumière de la
question que vient de vous posé Monsieur
Alain méard ce que recherche avant tout
le CSA c'était naturel mais sauf que la
loi le dit aussi c'est l'intérêt du
public parmi les trois projets que vous
présentez est-ce que l'on peut déduire
de ce que vous venez de nous dire que
c'est Chéry HD qui vous paraît le mieux
répondre à l'intérêt du public et pas
simplement à vos perspectives de
développement économique et il a été
répondu qu'il y avait le côté pour
l'entreprise et puis pour le public
effectivement une chaîne à destination
des femmes aujourd'hui manque sur
l'offre de la TNT gratuite voilà nous
pensons que pour l'intérêt général pour
le pluralisme et pour la complémentarité
des offres ché HD est vraiment une
chaîne je pense qui remplira ce
manque
oui donc la question nous avait été
posée à trois reprises
oui il me semble que on a là une piste
pour la réponse à la question sur la
qualité c'est l'intérêt du public et
peut-être pas l'intérêt des publics mais
je réserve la la suite de ces réflexions
pour le rapport je vous remercie je n'ai
plus de
question merci monsieur le rapporteur
une dernière question qui me permet de
de rebondir sur ce qui avait été abordé
en en début d'audition vous aviez
signalé des des marques d'intérêt à une
certaine époque pour chaînes du groupe
euh le la loi de 2016 a modifié la loi
de
86 en ce qui concerne l'agrément par
l'arcom du changement de contrôle des
chaînes en en sanctuarisant une période
de de de 5 ans euh en interdisant la la
revente pendant ces 5 ans avec une
dérogation
sauf s'il y a une question de viabilité
économique est-ce que vous faites partie
de de ceux qui souhaitent un un
assouplissement de cette de cette mesure
parce que on a une on a une disposition
qui qui prévoit une dérogation en cas de
problème de viabilité économique de de
la chaîne mais on pourrait très bien
imaginer que F fasse avoir une vision
plus positive prospective siil un
intérêt d'un d'un pro projet quelle est
quelle est votre position par rapport à
cette question de de revendre d'une
chaîne et de sanctualisation d'une
période de de 5 ans donc cette
disposition elle a été votée à la
suiteette disposition été vée à la
suite merci donc je disais que cette
disposition a été votée à la suite on le
sait de la revente de la chaîne numéro
23 au bout de de 2
ans et on comprend tout à fait que la
loi avait pour
objectif de de prévenir les vités
spéculatives qui auraient pu être fait
par certains éditeurs au moment où il
devenait attributeur d'une d'une
ressource rare qui est la la ressource
hertienne effectivement nous faisons
ceux nous faisons partie de ceux qui
plaident pour un assouplissement voir
une suppression de cette disposition
pourquoi bah ça a déjà été dit devant le
Sénat ou qui avait parlé à l'époque
d'une vitrification du secteur euh avec
cette disposition parce que la loi nous
semble avoir une portée trop générale et
qui quelque part met sur un même pied
des acteurs qui viennent d'arriver sur
la TNT et des acteurs qui ont euh été
présent depuis 20 ans donc c'est ça qui
pour nous et est ce ce caractère très
général de la loi qui qui qui est qui
est un souci d'autre part on sait que
l'arcom encadre euh les changements de
contrôle euh de manière très stricte il
y a le besoin d'aller demander
l'agrément de l'arcom si jamais il y a
il y a le changement de contrôle d'un
d'un éditeur donc
voilà peut-être une question euh
prospective encore est-ce que vous avez
bien l'intention de renouveler la
demande d'autorisation de la chaîne euh
voilà et dans dans ce cas est-ce que
vous pensez que les obligations
auxquelles pour l'instant la la
convention vous soumet euh devraiit
évoluer u et dans quel sensu
oui donc comme le président Jean-Paul
becrou vient de le confirmer oui nous
serons candidats pour une réattribution
d'énergie 12 à l'horizon de février
2025 et quelle était deè partie de la
question l'évolution de la convention ah
l'évolution de la convention ah bah ça
il est il est il est trop tôt
aujourd'hui l'appel à candidature n'a
pas été publié par l'arcom on va
regarder l'appel à candidature lorsqu'il
sortira on va préparer notre dossier de
candidature
et bah c'est à ce moment-là qu'on va se
poser la question de savoir si on soumet
des dispositions oou on propose des
obligations supplémentaires sur un
certain nombre de sujets et à contrario
est-ce qu'il y en a sur lesqueles on
souhaite moduler aujourd'hui honnêtement
c'est pas c'est pas une question qu'on a
travaillé à date euh et ça ça va
probablement être dans le trimestre ou
le semestre qui qui vient dans le cadre
de l'appel à
candidature dans ce cas-là vous avez
peut-être réfléchi à une procédure
idéale de l'appel à candidature même si
vous n'avez pas la responsabilité de
lancer cet appel à candidature j'imagine
que outre le résultat idéal qui est de
vous renouveler une autorisation vous
avez peut-être une idée sur la façon
dont ça devrait se passer pour que ce
soit
idéal au risque de vous surprendre non
on a l'habitude je pense les uns et les
autres d'avoir candidaté par le passé
conformément à cette procédure on on
sentre notre énergie à à préparer ce
dossier est-ce qu'il y a une procédure
idéale bon j'ai l'impression que même si
on avait une réponse à cette questionlà
elle seraitvine donc finalement on on va
rentrer dans le cadre de la procédure
qui lui-même est encadré par la loi et
donc voilà on va être un acteur
responsable qui va répondre dans le
cadre de la procédure et de la loi du
mieux qui qu' nous
paraîit
en en conclusion est-ce que vous avez
des
préconisations particulières à faire à
la à la commission
d'enquête à ma connaissance vous aez
plus non monsieur
président très bien je vous je vous
remercie donc nous allons lever la la
séance vous pouvez de toute façon nous
faire par des contributions écrites si
vous souhaitez préciser certaines de vos
interventions donc rendez-vous à
14h30 pour la prochaine
audition